hey liam how you doing hey morgan's good
yourself
i'm doing good so i have to tell you my
ideal friday night is a new liam neeson
action film with like a giant bowl of
popcorn so this is right up my alley
congrats on film
thank you thank you very much um your
character has this great line in the
movie you know where he says you name it
i've probably done it do you sort of
feel that way about this amazing acting
career of yours do you feel like at this
point you know you've done it all
um
i've done quite a few things but i i um
i'm tempted
i'm tempted to to break into comedy in
some weird way but uh
um
i'd like to i'd like to try a comedic
film where
i make a total tit of myself
so uh
so we're working on that we're working
on doing that i've been offered this uh
uh a reboot of naked gum i don't know if
you remember those films led the the
great the great leslie nielsen did
a number of years ago
seth macfarlane is writing
one for me so let's see how that goes
it'll probably end my career
no
i'm gonna say no on that so i have to
tell you when i first heard this news
my dad would spend sundays at home with
there's five kids in my family and we
would watch the naked gun films all the
time he was a huge fan of leslie nielsen
so i'm so excited for this uh what was
your reaction when you were first
approached about this remake
i was uh
i i
i mean i had such respect for those
leslie nielsen films too
because they were so
silly and yeah incredibly
watchable because of leslie nielsen
he was always known as a kind of a heavy
in his career in his early
[Music]
so i
but because i know seth macfarlane a
little bit he directed me in the film
several years ago and i i like the guy
very much i think he's very clever
yeah
but we haven't got a script yet so so
we'll see it's early days
i love that what makes you think that's
going to end your career you don't think
you can do the comedy well because i
know you can do it
i wish i wish i had your confidence but
we'll see
i will i will have it for you um and
also you know how much people when
you're on that jimmy fallon on the
tonight show recently uh people loved
your blue steel
oh you saw my blue steel yeah oh yeah i
mean not only was it impressive it was
slightly intimidating i like
it okay
so i was looking at your imdb and it's
pretty wild you know when you think of
your career the first film that i can
see that you were in you know on screen
was pilgrim's progress uh so
and that came out in 1978 you know so
you've been doing this for almost 45
years i want to know what keeps you
interested year after year
um i listen i love my job i feel humbled
to be in it
it beats real work
trying to teach six and seven-year-old
kids
that beats working on a building site
which i've done
i just and sometimes i nip myself in the
arm and i think i'm lucky i've been
i just but just before christmas i i
finished my 100th
film
and
i was playing phillip marlowe the
raymond champers classic private eye
for neil jordan who's a wonderful film
director and writer
um so i can't believe it i really can't
believe i made 100 movies
if someone had told me at the age when i
was 15 or 16
this is what i'd be doing i would not
have believed them at all
well uh we
love you and we always want more from
you so to hear i was also seeing your
imdb there's so many more movies in
post-production but to hear about a
naked gun remake with you starring in it
cannot wait so nice getting to talk to
you
thanks maureen appreciate it